this is my chance to prove myself
sup guys wait a minute you guys aren't
the real Avengers
I can tell Hulk gives it away
Oh
[Music]
there's a new top no you seen that
before
no with that skirt you should probably
stop staring with Laurie it's creepy
though too late guys are losers so to
become an Avenger other like trials or
any movie you just don't do anything I
would do and definitely don't do
anything I wouldn't do
there's a little gray area in there and
that's where you operate oh all right
that's not a hug look I'm just grabbing
the top for you all right kid
good luck out there listen I know school
sucks
Peter you still with us uh yeah yeah I
know you want to save the world but
you're not rid of your the spider-man no
not I'm not this is just costume this is
for the ceiling stay close to the ground
stay out of trouble
forget the flying monster guy there are
people who handle this sort of thing you
can treat me like a kid all the time but
you are a kid this is my chance to prove
myself
yeah what is going on with you I'm sorry
I'm so busy I'm slammed
don't mess with me cuz I will kill you
and everybody you blow
you
hey true believers is Charlie this is
going to be so awesome so spider-man
trailer let's break it down there is a
new round of the spider-man giveaway
that's going on right now - all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on this video be sure to
click that Bell to enable alerts so that
you don't miss out on anything I just
love the Avengers run it you guys
totally are not the Avengers this movie
is all about him still becoming
spider-man like Iron Man gives him that
speech look kid you're not ready for the
big stuff yet leave the flying man in
the suit - people like the Avengers
there are people that handle that so
he's trying to become an a-list Avenger
even though he kind of already joined
the team in Captain America Civil War
that was kind of like his tryout but you
get a taste for his life in school like
him just sitting there obviously you see
zendaya over there her name is Michelle
in the movie you can see she looks kind
of dumpy so I wonder if there's going to
be some arc in the film or in the
trilogy where she ends up becoming like
super model hot just because in real
life this is what she looks like most of
the time so the way she talks about
herself in the movie she's probably
Michelle Gonzalez who's like a really
badass detective that Spiderman works
with she was his girlfriend for a period
in the comics when he was not with Mary
Jane so even though they're doing really
classic Spiderman stuff they're trying
to do it in a way that they haven't done
before that's why we have Michael Keaton
vulture who is supposed to have this
horrific entrance like the way they cut
him into the trailer he seems kind of
scary but Tom Hollands spoke about him
like he was going to terrify Peter the
first time he appears so you see a
little bit about his creation that's
[ __ ] our tech leftover from the Avengers
invasion so you see this has already
become an Avengers world they said the
whole reason for going with a look like
this as opposed to say a comic book look
with the feathers it's just because a
lot of the aesthetic of the Marvel
movies flows from Iron Man's technology
so it just makes sense that you would
have technology based villains like this
so classic spider-man villains with a
slight Tony Stark Marvel twist but we
see a longer scene of him jumping off
the Washington Monument testing out his
glider tech Kevin Feige teased there'd
be all kinds of bells and whistles we
haven't seen yet with the suit but
that's just like the spider like things
that you saw from the comics all the
stuff that Tony Stark built into the
suit is going to be classics
my term and stuff the whole idea here is
that they're restoring spider-man to his
true self like that's the whole idea and
bringing him back to Marvel bringing him
home so all the stuff that they add to
the suit like everybody's wondering what
else it does is all stuff that goes way
back in the comics so we've already seen
a couple things that it can do like
we've seen the stark tech web-shooters
we've seen the digital readout on the
spider light which is also right out of
the comics you know I wouldn't be
surprised if he has some advanced
communication devices in there too like
you see him flying with Iron Man at the
end of the trailer there's probably some
tech built in there to help his suit
communicate with Iron Man's suit but it
isn't like a full Iron Man suit I
wouldn't be surprised though if it's
resistant to like knife wounds but it
probably couldn't stop a really big
bullet or like a giant energy blast like
the vulture has here so even though it's
a stark tech suit it's not as strong as
a Tony Stark
Iron Man suit or even like black
panther's vibranium weave costume
although that would be really badass a
Spider Man vibranium weave costume maybe
for the second infinity war film you see
him hanging out with Ned Leeds here this
is one of his best friends in high
school he eventually becomes Hobgoblin
in the comics I don't know what kind of
plans they have for that in the Marvel
Universe that might never come to pass
but you can see the homecoming banner
here it's spider-man homecoming because
there's a homecoming dance in high
school and he's also coming home to
Marvel so one of my other favorite parts
of the Comic Con footage was in here too
him getting in trouble for watching
footage of himself on YouTube like he's
watching a clip from that Airport battle
scene of him swinging around ant-man
the other big thing that's different
from really big spider-man movies too is
Ned Leeds then in the trailer finds out
his identity that typically didn't
happen in spider-man films till much
much later in the trilogy's but usually
if it was Harry he kept the big secret
from him and it became this big rift
between them but now one of his best
friends knows his secret maybe Michelle
will learn his secret through the course
of the film to the iron man's speech is
just so great - don't do anything I
would do don't do anything I wouldn't do
that gray area in between that's where
you operate then gives him that awkward
Tony Stark I'm not your dad I'm afraid
of intimacy hug as he pushes him out the
door it's like a hug and pushing
out the door at the exact same time
classic Tony Stark move he's given it to
thousands of women in the past but you
can kind of see how he doesn't want to
acknowledge the e thinks of Peter as
like a son or he's not a father figure
he's one of those people that's almost
afraid to tap into certain emotions that
he feels like he might have like he has
that psychoanalysis sit down with the
Hulk at the end of Iron Man 3 let's not
open that can of worms maybe dr. strange
can help him with that because he's an
actual trained physician but don't you
just wonder looking at this Michael
Keaton footage what it is that they said
to him they convinced him to sign back
on for the movie because he was rumored
for the role a long time ago last year
and then reportedly he turned it down
but then later it came back on so I
wonder if they changed the script or
they changed something about the
character or they showed him something
that he really enjoyed but I just love
the idea of a vicious evil Michael
Keaton he's one of those actors that has
this intensity that you don't see a lot
and he gets so meta when you think about
him as Batman like that's one of the
reasons why his Batman was so great just
because he was so intense but the thing
about Peter here isn't the way they cut
this trailer makes it look like the
vulture has just handed him his ass like
he's almost crying here he's in the
hoodie still so this seems like it's
before he has the stark tech suit so
like that teaser yesterday that looks
like it took place before Captain
America Civil War where he gets that
stark tech suit maybe this film will
jump back and forth in time just a
little bit because they said they're not
doing the Uncle Ben origin story but
they'll at least acknowledge it somehow
but most of this film is going to be
localized to Queens with the exception
of that Washington Monument shot in the
scenes where you see him walking around
the Avengers building with Tony Stark so
at some point he will go see a bunch of
cool stuff happening at the Avengers
base but this big action set piece here
does this not remind you of that
spider-man 2 Tobey Maguire train scene
except he's holding a giant fairy
together from getting ripped apart so
it's just like that much crazier that
gives you an idea of how strong his
webbing is but it sounds like just based
on the tone of this trailer that you
know Tony Stark is only going to be in a
little bit of the movie but we'll help
him out with whatever the big final
battle is going to be because you see a
couple different types of fights in here
you see him facing off against the fake
Avengers robbers using sheet re tech to
brought that atm
he takes them down pretty quickly but
things start to escalate as you see the
vulture come in just crash through the
ceiling here
so very quickly things spiral out of
control and that's where Uncle Tony
comes in but let me know what do you
think about Spider Man in high school
like a lot of this is just very a day in
the life of spider-man like he has to go
to school just like everybody else so
every time something crazy happens and
he wants to go help he has to find an
excuse to leave so there is some
comic-con footage that they did not
include in this but it's just of
Michelle chasing him out in the hallway
just going where are you going Peter
Parker like every time he runs away but
it'll be really fun to see how they
tried to distinguish the cinematography
of spider-man in this new Marvel film
because if you go back and you watch the
Tobey Maguire the Andrew Garfield films
they slowly tried to be more in more
advanced with the way they shot him like
when you look at this amazing spider-man
Andrew Garfield trailer it's all
first-person perspective for a large
portion of it like you don't even see
the spider suit in it but the big
difference with Tom Holland is that like
even that teaser that they just dropped
it's all first-person but it's like he's
filming himself so it's like Spider Man
for a YouTube generation like YouTube
exists in this world so of course Spider
Man would film himself doing stunts
that's even a big part of how he earned
money working at the Daily Bugle
following spider-man around
quote-unquote like I know Spider Man
really well he lets me take pictures of
him so Peter Parker we're going to be
following spider-man around it be all
video so just imagine a whole bunch of
selfies of spider-man just doing crazy
trick shots taking villains down but as
you can see it's the exact same suit
from Civil War you know maybe a few
minor upgrades during the film it's all
CG even though he does wear a cloth suit
on set like this is what it looks like
when he's walking around while they're
filming and if you guys didn't know they
do the exact same thing for Robert
Downey jr. he has not worn an actual
Iron Man suit on set in a long time it's
all CG 100% so just imagine when they're
shooting this Captain America Civil War
scene Robert Downey jr. is just walking
around like this in his street clothes
but a lot of you are asking how is this
going to connect to the other Avengers
films so largely I
they want spider-man to feel like his
own self-contained universe with other
Avengers stuff happening in the
background that's where you have Tony
Stark the Avengers building Chitauri
tech leftover for the Avengers invasion
but a lot of his core characters will be
people from Queens that he goes to
school with so even when he's swinging
around the city trying to help people
it's still gonna feel relatively
self-contained like he's not going to be
jetting across the world every single
day but what they'll probably do is at
least one of the post-credits scenes
will be a related Avengers film like
it'll be an Iron Man moment or it'll be
something for one of the other big films
but let me know in the comments which
post-credit scenes do you want to see
them attach to spider-man they could do
Thor but that's kind of unrelated it's
out in outer space he's never met Thor
before they could do a direct Avengers
tie-in that's actually more likely but
if anything I think they'll just be
teasing the next spider-man film just
because it will be a trilogy Tom
Hollands signed on for three films who
knows how many he'll do after that but
that does not include his Marvel
contract to do the Avengers crossover so
if spider-man comes into one of the
other Marvel films that's like a
completely separate deal from a business
standpoint but if anything I'm hoping
that we see a little bit from his friend
from Brooklyn although we don't really
know where Captain America is as of
right now he's kind of on the run last
time scene in Wakanda with Bucky in
Black Panther so it looks great so far
but this is just the teaser trailer
we'll probably get a whole bunch more
story the next time they drop a trailer
which will probably be around the
Superbowl but there is a second trailer
they're dropping tonight like an
international version of the trailer
that has a little bit of different
footage so I'll totally do a video for
that too but that won't post til later
in the morning but I just I love the
idea that they're just dropping this
alright now they could have totally
waited till next year
but Kevin Feige was just like nah we're
just gonna all dump it right now here
you go everybody have fun so first
spider-man giveaway winner
congratulations to Spider fan you win a
comixology gift card please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details I'll
name another winner when I post that new
trailer video in a couple hours so get
hype good time to be a true believer
right now well you guys wait for that to
post you can click here for my ranking
all the spider-man movies so far and you
can click here to learn all about Savitt
are on the flat
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you